one of the strongest ways I've been able
to gain access to people far above my
pay grade is to provide Big Value in
essence pretend the person paid me for
twenty five thousand dollars to do
something that level of effort gets
someone to say this is too much I can't
believe you did all this how can I repay
you so for example a few years ago I
entered a new networking group and I
scheduled calls with every single person
in the group and I prepared for a few
hours up to a day before each call with
things I thought that would help them
based on some research I did and the
skills I had and they were so blown away
they asked me what they could do and I
usually didn't have anything but just
having a stack of ious up to the ceiling
that I could call up whenever I actually
needed help was one of the highest
degrees of Leverage things I did in my
life on the early days when I didn't
have enough money to buy help